By noon the dragon filled the house
it's head hung over the front door
it's tail hung over the back door
and the rest of the rooms in the house that didn't have
some part of the dragon in it
[hmmm]
I bet that there is a house like that on
some of you live, you know
where there's a lot of houses
some of you live in appartments
doesn't really matter
but I bet you if you live in a house
on a block of houses
there's at least one house
on that street
where the tail of the dragon
has started to come out of the house
and you know what that's like ey
because it's
the house that you don't really
want to look at when you walk by
you know?
and maybe, I dunno,
it needs a new roof
and like the door is a little bit crooked
'nd the lawn isn't cut 'nd
you know there's some rusty things
laying around there 'nd like,
it's just not taken care of!
and you know!
and maybe you know from the gossip
in the neighborhood too
that there's something going on in that house
that is
just    not     good
and it's got to the pont where it's SO not good
that it's starting to spread itself out beyond
the domestic confines of the house, so
you know you ru,
you run into people like that
now and then too you'll
notice this so
you know sometimes,
I don't know if this has happened
to any of you but, it might've,
It's happened to you in some ways
you know that there are
those people who can't not
tell you everything about
what's going on in their life
even if you've hardly even met them
if ya, if you see someone who's
REALLY in trouble
you know, you'll sit on the bus 'nd
somebody who's
clearly
on the road to being
thoroughly deranged
will sit down
beside you and they'll start
telling you about the problems
of their life
's like you know that
the dragon that they're dealing with
is so big that they can't
even contain it.
they're so desperate
to have it DEALT with
that they
CAN'T
not talk about it.
you know, and there's lots of
people like that
they're the ones,
what is... that... stupid little phrase?
TMI right? too much information?
's like, yeah!
well, w-why does that happen?
it's because
people are dealing with anomalies
'n unexpected occurrences 'n tragedies
and they cannot articulate
a solution
and most people
think by talking
which is also part of the reason
that therapy works
well do you think?
I doubt it
you might!
but very few people think!
you know, so if you wanna
solve a problem you wanna
talk it over with a friend.
And so, you know you might just
think that you're talking about
the problem, so that you know
what the problem is
but you're talking about it so
you don't
when you talk about it
you articulate the problem space.
You start to generate potential
hypothesis
about solutions, but
more than that,
if you're talking to someone
you can watch them,
just like the little kid with the mouse
would watch the mother, 'ts like well,
here's what I think the problem is
'n if you go
you know you're listening 'n you go
like that
you roll your eyes
you know, it's a hint!
to the person
that maybe that's not the most
appropriate way to formulate the problem
now maybe you don't roll your
eyes but
you don't encourage them
or maybe they tell you
what the problem is
'n you're really actively
engaged
and you're nodding
well then they know that
maybe they formulated it
the way that someone half sane
and tolerable would formulate it
and then they can walk through
the solution.
So...
so, when you sit down beside
someone
and theyhave to tell you everything
one of the things that you know is that
they don't have anyone to listen
to them
and
part of what happens in therapy
a huge part of it is that
you just listen.
I have one client,
that's all I ever do with her!
She comes in once every
two weeks
and I just sit their and listen to her
for an hour
and
now I can maybe have
a bit of a discussion with her
for the last ten minutes.
But if I try to say
anything
for the first 50 minutes
she just,
looks kinda irritated 'n
you know, it's like I've
interrupted the flow of the
of the interaction
and she's alone.
She doesn't have anybody to talk to.
so
you know
she wants to listen to herself think!
and she can't do that by herself
she has to have someone
to do it with
and so
you know
people think by talking
'n some people have no one
to talk to
'n so
their problems start to
spill out
'n you know by that time
you can't even help them
usually, because
if you listen for three years
it wouldn't be enough listening
you'd just listen forever
n you'd never get to the bottom of it.